we're gonna need more diapers oh wait
it's pregnant women who glow Brides
blush okay I'm really excited to be here
oh I mean at a wedding and any wedding
it just so happens to be your wedding
boilers Bartholomew Henry Alan that's
not a good name look are you sure I
don't you can Bart feels more natural to
me
can we go with Bart bars kind of cool
and doesn't wasn't born until Springs
I'm pregnant we are all Jo in that
moment when they keep mentioning people
being pregnant people looking like they
glow as pregnant ladies do like they're
sitting with all the women they're
pregnant ladies glow you're glowing iris
oh I'm not ready for that which means
it's probably right around the corner so
we need to talk about how the show has
been beating us in the face with Barry
and irises children the tornado twins
along with Bart Allen and Joe's baby
which opens up a whole can of speedforce
worms so if you are finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there'll be a new round of the flash
ring giveaway at the end of the video
too so starting with the important stuff
first those clips I included obviously
tell a very specific story Barry and
iris will probably find out that they're
paraded by at the end of the season but
the thinker clip where he says the
Nazarene wasn't born until spring what's
happening this spring the finale is
happening who's pregnant right now and
seems like the due date based on the
timing might be near the finale Cecile
is pregnant so does that imply that her
baby is the nazarene that the thinker is
foreshadowing but when you take a step
back remember what was the first episode
called it was called the flash reborn so
the idea of people being born or reborn
is really important to this season
leading to a lot of really interesting
foreshadowing for season 5 which is why
I believe that girl during Barry's
wedding who seemed so awkward and happy
to be there for his specific wedding
with iris West is his daughter one of
his two children one of the tornado
twins she'll come back but won't be a
really big
thing until season five just because
you're jumping the gun you're putting
the cart before the horse they just got
married
iris doesn't know if she's pregnant or
not it sounds like if any baby is going
to be born by the end of the season it
will just be Cecile's in they'll turn
Barry and iris children's stuff Bart
Allen the future speedsters that flow
from them into future seasons so just
remember not to get too far ahead of
yourself when you're wondering which new
speedsters they'll bring on the show in
future seasons first they have to do
Barry and iris getting married then they
have to do the deed she has to get
pregnant give birth and then you can get
to Bart Allen but if you ever wondered
why they wanted to get those to marry
this early in the show's run because
it's only season four usually comic book
characters getting married is sort of
the ultimate happy ending for their
story and it gets pushed at the final
season like Smallville during season 10
the real big reason why they're racing
to this finish line to make as many
flash puns as possible is is because
they want to get to Bart Allen and all
those cool speedster stories that they
could tell literal flash family stories
but you can't do that until you do this
other stuff first so it's just a bunch
of boxes that you check plus you know
they want to get them together because
they'll ultimately get together so it's
like why don't we do this now so that we
don't have to wait till season eight
nine ten to do those really cool stories
the show has a history of burning
through plot really fast think about how
fast they move through the flashpoint
storyline two episodes max to address
that so if you're not super familiar
with the flash family tree what happens
is as Barry and iris get together they
have twins dawn and Dawn Allen I know
it's kind of funny but the way they name
characters back during the Silver Age
was a little bit silly they're born but
the first time that you meet them is
actually as adults like you don't go
through the process of watching iris
give birth and them growing up so the
circumstances of their birth is also
this really big thing so what happened
is is in the lead-up to crisis on
Infinite Earths we find out that iris
West is secretly from the 30th century
Barry goes and joins her there for a
brief period they conceived the twins
but before they're born
Barry dies during Infinite Crisis so the
tornado twins grow up hearing about the
heroic exploits of their father but
never really
getting a chance to know him so remember
the tornado twins were largely
characters that happened during the
Wally West era along with Bart Allen
so Barry himself in the comics doesn't
know these characters very well so
that's why it's such a big deal that his
daughter come back to meet him but
remember that future newspaper that we
keep coming back to flash vanishes in
crisis during 2020 for which is about
season 10 of the TV show would mean that
if they stay according to their plan
their roadmap that they would imply
Barry dies saving everyone during their
version of crisis on Infinite Earths
and his children grow up never having
really known him so wouldn't it be funny
if his daughter also a speedster comes
back in time to get a chance to meet him
on their wedding day
now that's assuming a whole lot of plot
points that could always change down the
road they tend to change their plans
even within seasons they make course
corrections so they might try for their
crisis on Infinite Earths much sooner
with a much different outcome because
for the most part the show has a hopeful
tone but what it sounds like the show
might end up doing is genuine flash
family stuff in future seasons it could
either uses children for that or it
could go straight to Bart Allen but I
feel like they have to introduce the
concept of his children first which is
where this woman comes in here then just
building towards a reveal like first
they tease something like the tease
killer frost they tease gorilla grodd in
the pilot episode then you learn a
little bit more about him then finally
you get to see him on screen so just
expect the same treatment with various
children in Bart Allen but I don't think
I need to talk too much about the origin
of Bart Allen most of you know where
that character comes from the fact that
his father Don Allen marries Melanie
Thawne and that's how you get the half
Thawne half Alan speedster which is why
the reverse-flash hates Bart Allen so
much you're part of my bloodline your
family I hate you so much the big
question now though is Cecile's baby
because they could do one of two things
they could try to change something from
the comics and turn it into the Daniel
West because there are members of the
West family that becomes speedsters and
it becomes it's really heartbreaking
twist during the new 52 run or the less
likely scenario is is that they give it
a different name and turn it into
something completely different that's
not from the comics
Cecille surprisingly is actually a
comic-book character I talked about her
during my episode 10 trailer video I'll
link that at the end of this but she was
actually the person who defended Barry
during the trial of the flash and that's
the story that we're getting ready for
when the show comes back in January so I
think they're trying to use her in a
more substantial way which is why
they're doing this baby storyline so
that you care more about her you
genuinely care and want to see this baby
born but when the thinker has all this
crazy stuff going on and they make
reference to a Nazarene being born in
spring it just makes the hair on the
back of your neck raise up like they're
gonna do something to Cecile like maybe
the baby will be born but they'll wind
up killing her off or one of the other
Bane characters so we're going to need
more diapers will happen at the end of
the season that'll be really happy but
it'll come after a really sad moment
because that's usually how they end the
seasons some big WTF moment to make you
cry but then something else to get you
really excited about what they're doing
next season and as all these clips imply
like I've been saying they're implying
that they're getting ready to do flash
family stuff so let me know in the
comments how fast do you think they're
going to go to bury and Irish children
and how long do you think it's gonna be
before they pay off his daughter coming
to the wedding
and we see a genuine version of Bart
Allen but it should be said that because
the showrunner Andrew Kreisberg was
fired earlier this year it's always
possible that they change what they
originally intended to do Kevin Smith
said that Andrew Kreisberg before he was
fired told him what they planned on
doing during season five and it blew his
mind Kevin Smith is a huge comic book
person that's why he tends to direct the
flash and Supergirl because they tend to
be more comic book II than arrow so it
implies that they were getting ready to
do flash family stuff Kevin Smith being
a huge fan of classic flash comics but
because now Greg Berlanti himself is
running both of the flash and Supergirl
grooms it's possible that the flash
storyline just changes a little bit but
we'll probably find out about that when
the show comes back in January so if we
learn anything about the direction of
the show changing I'll let everybody
know
so no worries there but there is a new
round of that flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment about the
flash on the video
announce a new winner when I post a new
DC there's been a bunch of Titans
dropping recently to maybe some new
stuff next week but click
here for all my Star Wars the last Jedi
Easter eggs and click here for that
brand new flash video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you